all right guys
bang bang i've got an awesome treat with
you today
uh rob is here thanks so much for doing
this man yeah thanks for having me
so uh you are like mr tesla now there's
like elon musk and then there's you
uh maybe let's start with uh with just
your background
and uh and kind of how did all of this
happen yeah
i don't know that i would rank it in
that order but as far as the background
of tesla daily goes
so i run a podcast uh now youtube
channel called tesla daily
and the podcast started just as an audio
podcast you know published
published on apple podcast stitcher
things like that
back in uh sort of mid-2017
uh the reason i started the podcast was
because i think you know probably
similar to how you feel with bitcoin
there's just so much
you know misinformation and
misunderstanding around tesla at the
time
and the media reporting was you know
only amplifying that misunderstanding
so you would see articles in mainstream
media like cnbc complaining about you
know oh there's like another
tesla accident today and the tesla
caught on fire so like obviously the
company is doomed and then the stock
would go down
you know five ten percent on that news
when if you actually look at the data a
tesla vehicle
even at that time was much safer in
terms of the number of fires happening
per
you know mile driven uh by the you know
five to ten times safer
so things like that just weren't really
getting out there and i've been a tesla
investor since
uh sort of early 2013 in 2013.
so i'd been you know sort of obsessing
about the company for
the better part of almost you know four
or five years at that point reading
everything i could you know probably
three hours a day after i got done with
my normal job
just spending everything i could on
every amount of time that i could
absorbing everything possible about the
company
so seeing that information out there was
frustrating and you know over time i'd
convince some friends to also invest in
tesla
and every time articles like that would
come out there would be you know
i'd probably have like five or ten texts
being like okay is this a big deal like
what should i sell my stock what's going
on
uh so i figured okay i'm spending all
this time about tesla i'm not quite
learning as much anymore because i kind
of understand the vision of the company
at this point
uh but i could probably be helping other
people sort of you know
fit all this information contextualize
all this information and make sure that
it's accurate for people
so that's when i had the idea to start
the tesla daily podcast i did
did it daily because everything you know
as we've seen over the last few years is
changing so rapidly with tesla that
you know by the time two days have gone
by there's already three new stories on
tesla and the news is already old and
people have
absorbed it and traded on it and things
like that so i didn't know if it would
stay that way forever
i didn't know if there was enough demand
for tesla information but
over time you know the story has just
gotten bigger and bigger there's been
more and more news
more and more people following tesla
closely and i think you know some of the
mainstream media coverage has gotten
better over the years
but there's definitely still missing
context and missing information out
there that
you know my whole goal is to try to help
people contextualize and understand that
so that's sort of the the essence of
tesla daily about a year ago i started
you know doing it full-time took the
audio podcast with the help of just
listener support honestly on patreon uh
to full time
started the youtube channel so i think
that's been great in terms of you know
helping get
more good information out to more people
which is really the point uh and then
you know that's just seen crazy growth
over the last year
almost up to 100 000 subscribers now
which is you know i never thought
that it would be anything close to that
one starting out so it's been really
cool to just sort of
you know follow the journey and kind of
help people follow along with me
and so when i uh said early on you know
there's elon musk and then there's you
when it comes to tesla uh i was joking a
little bit
alluding to the situation uh on the
earnings calls maybe talk a little bit
about
uh what the hell happened there yeah
sure so
i think tesla has done a really good job
with
sort of bringing retail investors along
a lot of
companies they just uh you know they'll
take the questions from the analysts
every quarter or maybe they'll take like
five or six they'll get their company
update and then you know
radio silence for the next you know 90
days or whatever the case is
uh tesla's done a really good job of
sort of making giving the opportunity
to retail investors to be more
interactive uh you know they
i think they took uh
i think the pivotal moment for this was
when they took a call from
uh galileo russell of hyperchange i
don't know if you're familiar with him
at all but you know similar sort of
stuff that i'm doing covering tesla
really closely
uh on youtube he's been doing that for a
few years and he
he managed to get on one of the
conference calls and elon said okay like
the analyst questions are you know
boring and boneheaded right now let's
cut to youtube and then galley comes on
and
shoots off five or ten questions elon
keeps letting him ask questions and
stuff like that so
that was sort of the pivotal moment of
retail investors sort of becoming
involved
and then tesla's also part with a
company called say that allows
shareholders to sort of connect to their
brokerage
and vote their shares for questions to
be asked each quarter
so for you know the last few quarters
i've been able to sort of
you know come up with good questions and
then my audience has supported those
questions and voted them to the top to
the point where i can get
you know one two or three questions last
quarter was you know sort of the first
three questions on that platform
um on the earnings call so it's just
something that tesla has done you know
they're disrupting
in so many different spaces but i think
they're also disrupting and sort of
investor relations and investor
communication especially as it relates
to
retail investors which i think is really
important for a company like tesla that
is so you know consumer focused
and obviously has such massive interest
in the retail investment community so
yeah it's been really cool to have sort
of those opportunities and get to ask
questions that i think
oftentimes are a little bit more
insightful than what we might hear from
the analysts on the call that are just
really trying to get to the information
to update their models
yeah and how much of that is driven by
elon and kind of just his
uh very different way of approaching a
lot of this versus
um it's a corporate strategy or anything
like that
yeah i think i think it starts at the
top obviously you know if elon didn't
want to do it it wouldn't happen
i think tesla's got a really good team
in place around elon that sort of has
that same mentality of
you know let's start from scratch let's
build things up from the bottom let's
not really
conform to the norms that you know have
existed in the past whether that's in
automotive manufacturing or whether
that's an investor relations it's just
sort of the company culture
that tesla has and obviously that starts
with elon but i think it permeates
throughout the rest of the organization
throughout the
management team and i think we see that
you know play out all across the
business line
yeah and so i know that we were going to
spend a bunch of time talking about
battery day which
just happened and kind of all the
updates there but before we get there
let's just for those who maybe don't
know so much about the company just give
kind of an overview
uh of you know why is tesla so important
and kind of why is this company
specifically
uh seem to be always in the crosshairs
of headlines you know some positive some
negative but it just seems like people
can't
you know look away right they're always
paying for sure so so kind of
tell us a little bit about the company
and why you think that is yeah i mean
tesla's a fascinating company like i
said for me
i became aware of the company back in
2013 made a small investment at that
time and just
started learning more and more about the
company and really just
like as i became fascinated with and i
think a lot of other people have felt
similarly i think it's you know i always
compare it to apple
they're they're very different companies
and very different goals and things like
that but
for me i was really captivated with
apple apple was sort of my first
investment
um and for me it's really about
disruptive technology
you know i saw my friends with ipod
touches and it was just like oh my gosh
this is
people love these and this is obviously
where things are going and you know
they're gonna make a phone and then you
know they come out the iphone and it
just
you know snowballs from there um i think
you know there's similar
sort of passion around the products that
tesla has created people
really really really love the product
and that's where it starts that we
that's what elon's focus always is as we
start with the product we put every
single thing that we can into the
product
you know even to this day they still
don't advertise conventionally they
obviously do some marketing but
uh you know they don't pay for ads on tv
and they they prefer to put all that
money
into reinvesting and making the product
better so
that's where it starts that's where the
product focus happens and that allows
them to
create this disruptive product that we
saw with you know the model s back in
2012.
so tesla's original sort of master plan
that elon published back in 2006 was
okay we're going to build
a really expensive sports car that was
this tesla roadster built on the lotus
elise
sort of chassis they look almost
identical um
that was like 120 130 000 you know and
up
type of vehicle just because it's new
technology you know electric vehicles at
that time there wasn't
there was really no 200 plus mile range
electric vehicle
this was sort of first in the category
um and obviously people are interested
in that that's
disruptive technology in and of itself
but it's not very affordable not a lot
of people can buy 120 000
cars and you know tesla knew that but
their whole goal has been to
accelerate the transition to sustainable
energy and to sustainable transportation
so
what they said is okay we're going to
take this expensive car we're going to
take the profits from this we're going
to reinvest in the business
and try and build a more affordable car
so that was the second car the model s
that came out in 2012
you know starting price around 50 000 at
sort of the low end they eventually cut
that low end version just because
consumers weren't really happy with the
range that it was providing which was
like 160 miles
but the higher end models had you know
maybe an 80 000
price for 250 miles of range something
like that so
you know kind of a step change from
where they started with the roadster
then i think as people know they took
the profits from the model s and they
reinvested that
to eventually build the model three and
that's sort of been the step change and
i think that's where a lot of the
interest recently has come in from tesla
is this car is actually affordable now
it starts at you know thirty five
thousand thirty eight thousand dollars
roughly
in that ballpark and that's pretty close
to what the new average
selling price of a new vehicle in the
united states is so it gets in the more
in the mainstream people can start to
afford it people can start to use it
their neighbors their friends have it
and you just you experience the product
and you you know take it out for a drive
you see
this 17 inch touchscreen across the
across the dash you see
you know autopilot handling 95 of your
driving on the highway
you feel the electric power train the
instant torque of the vehicle
you see these high safety ratings that
can't be achieved with an internal
combustion engine vehicle because of the
structure of the vehicle
there's just all these different
advantages that sort of pile up and then
you start to get it you just say oh
this is disruption and no one else is
doing it and tesla is so far ahead
because they've been laser focused on
this
since 2003 and you know the other car
makers they
they've been pushing this can kicking
the scan down the road because
if they invest in electric vehicles that
are better than their internal
combustion engine vehicles
the customer's going to see that they're
going to stop buying this technology
internal combustion engine technology
that these automakers have put a century
of research and development capital
expenditures
and investment into so tesla's sort of
uniquely positioned in that they're an
electric vehicle pure play that's all
they're focused on
and pretty much the entire you know auto
industry
is trying to push that back as far as
they can and that just leads to this
wide gap
where tesla is you know growing rapidly
and everybody else is declining and
you know my perspective as a bullish
investor is that that's going to
continue
so sort of getting into the second part
catching us up to today tesla's
delivered the model three
that's a high volume vehicle they're
shipping you know 300 350 000 of those a
year
the model y is next so that's sort of
the crossover
version of the model 3 and that is
should be a bigger market because
crossovers have just become more popular
than the sedan form factor
so tesla thinks they can grow that to
you know outsell all the other vehicles
that tesla offers combined which would
be the model s the model x
which is sort of a luxury suv type of
vehicle and then the model three so
basically tesla's plan and always has
been and always will continue to be
just accelerate the advent of
sustainable energy by making electric
vehicles more affordable so similar to
what they're doing
you know what they did for model s to
model three making things more
affordable they're gonna do the exact
same thing again
with the model three to the next version
of the of whatever comes next
so at battery day they said you know in
three years probably
they're going to be able to sell a tesla
for you know 25 000.
and that's probably going to have a
range around 300 miles and that's going
to be
even more disruptive than what the model
3 has been when the model 3 has already
taken you know greater than 50
of the market share in the luxury
premium sedan space in the united states
so if you introduce a 25 000 vehicle and
that takes you know 50
of that market share you can start to
see why tesla is so highly valued
because there's just so much opportunity
for them to grow
and there's so little competition um in
this electric vehicle space that is
competitive
you know the other automakers are
definitely starting to try but again
they haven't been focused on it for the
last
you know better part of 20 years like
tesla has there's just so much catching
up to do
and it might just be a little bit too
late for them to be competitive at this
point
so that's sort of the long and short of
it um we can get into more of the
details but that's sort of
the goal of tesla's just continue to
ramp up volume yeah and i think that
what's so interesting about the company
is uh it started out as there's no way
they can create one type of car and it's
almost like the detractors move the goal
post over and over and over absolutely
right
it's like hey look they can't create the
first girl because they created it oh
they can't scale it then they scaled it
this is okay they can't do a second one
then they did that right they can't
reduce the price point then they do that
then they can't ski and like
you just kind of unpack this and you're
like what is the credible
uh kind of critique and one of my
favorite questions to ask people is like
the people who would disagree with your
view right so the people who actually
say look
this is all you know bogus and it's
going to zero or whatever like
what is their argument and kind of from
your perspective does
any of their argument have validity or
is it all just complete you know
nonsense
sure i think there's definitely sort of
a spectrum there in terms of sort of a
bear argument i think a lot of things
that are
put out there on the bearish side are
complete nonsense but there are
definitely people that have
good points and i think a lot of the you
know the more bearish arguments that i
can tend to see the argument for
centers around valuation so you know
tesla's hovering anywhere around 350
billion dollars to 450 billion dollars
in terms of the valuation
the most valuable automaker even though
they sell you know one percent of the
vehicles out there today
not even so that's that's a legitimate
question of okay should tesla be this
valuable at this stage of the company
and i can't fault for anybody for saying
that they aren't because
based on their profitability today
obviously they're not they're trading at
some time something like 700
to a thousand times earnings no one
would buy a company based on that
so it's all about the future growth so
the bull versus bear case really comes
down to how likely
you think that future growth is and how
much profitability tesla can
extract on that growth versus the
profitability outlook for
current automakers so you know tesla
trades at
two to three times what toyota's market
cap is
so the big question is okay even if
tesla does eventually grow to be this
you know multi-million
vehicle deliveries per year type of
company toyota delivers about 10 million
tesla aspires to grow to about double
that
people say okay even if they achieve
their you know their wildest ambitions
they're still only fairly valued today
but i think what a lot of people miss
you know from the from the bearish
perspective is that tesla's not just
selling cars they're selling
technology there's they're a tech
company mixed with the manufacturing
company
mixed with you know an insurance company
and there's all these things that tesla
is doing that other automakers aren't
and that's why tesla
in my point of view deserves a premium
valuation
and i think probably the easiest way to
explain that to people is
right now tesla sells an 8 000 software
option on
every car they sell not everybody opts
for that but the option is available
about you know 25 percent of people take
that so
if 25 percent of people are taking an 8
000 option that's adding 2 000
to every car they sell so and that's
software margin so that goes straight to
the bottom line obviously after
accounting for the research and
development costs and things like that
but from just a gross margin perspective
that
pretty much falls straight to the bottom
line super high margin no other
automakers are able to
capture that sort of high margin revenue
from software so that's where tesla's
premium evaluation comes in
and you if you extend that to the future
and you say okay
i do think tesla can sell 10 million
vehicles per year 20 million vehicles
per year
and you know okay let's just hold
everything else steady let's say that
they continue to sell that option for
eight thousand dollars
and let's say 25 percent of people
continue to opt for it then you have an
average selling price increase of 2 000
on 20 million vehicles that's 40 billion
dollars in revenue
and pretty much in pure gross profit
that tesla's able to capture every
single year on their vehicle sales
and that's assuming that autopilot
doesn't get any better that they don't
actually achieve full self-driving which
is something that elon is
you know highly confident in achieving
obviously the timelines on that
are always questionable but um even if
we just sort of hold
steady state 40 billion dollars a year
in gross profit you know you put a 20
multiple on that and that's already 800
billion dollars in market cap so
that would be tesla you know 2xing or
3xing before accounting for
you know the stationary storage business
the solar business tesla insurance like
all these other things
a full fully autonomous robo taxi
network which obviously just sort of
breaks the valuation
to the upside there's just so much so
much that tesla is doing that these
other car makers aren't really
positioned to do
and that's why you see the premium to
the valuation now
as far as the bare case goes it's pretty
simple it's okay tesla's not going to
achieve that
and if you look at some of the comments
that elon has made in the past like he's
not always
delivered on time almost everything that
he has said
will happen has happened eventually so
he's got a really good track record of
achieving it's just
sometimes leaked so when tesla says
they're going to deliver you know 20
million vehicles per year by 2030
maybe they won't do that maybe it'll be
5 million 10 million you know put
whatever number in there you want
but then if you go forward five years
okay well the odds are getting even more
increased there that
you know tesla does accomplish what they
set out to accomplish and a great
example of that
is back in you know 2014 elon musk said
that in 2020
tesla would deliver 500 000 vehicles
that year
and you know even with a global pandemic
this year they're on track for
pretty much achieving right around that
somewhere between you know 480 000 and
520 000 so
um it doesn't always happen on time but
elon's track record is is pretty good in
terms of delivering what he sets out to
do
but yeah the bear case is just that that
won't happen and if it doesn't then yeah
tesla's way overvalued right now
and so when we think through this
there's kind of two schools of thought
one
you know people will yell and scream and
say elon is a uh
scammer he's lying he's trying to pump
the stock kind of you know all the like
again really extreme
bear uh type arguments the other that
would be like the
technological optimist would say hey
they're trying to do something that's
never been done before and therefore you
need people who
are constantly pushing the pace they're
putting these you know really big
audacious goals out there
uh really driving the team to kind of
accomplish almost the impossible
uh and therefore of course you're not
gonna be a hundred percent
every time but if you hit fifty percent
of those goals the progress you're make
is gonna be incredible
um you know and kind of if you
eventually get there but you're just off
on
timing then this is going to be a really
really valuable company
and to me it's always felt like uh
you're trying to
um hold somebody to you said
x number by y date you know perfectly uh
and it just always felt more like we
were in the the ladder bucket of like no
this is somebody who
uh is incredibly ambitious and they're
pushing the pace and
and they're trying to push a team to
literally create the future
and so sometimes they may be a little
late but actually we shouldn't
uh almost like ask them to temper their
expectations
we should be cheering them on and say
like can you go further and faster and
bigger and
and kind of you know even more ambitious
how do you
kind of balance that with he is running
a public company though
right and there are investors that are
kind of paying attention like how do you
just think through
the goal setting the milestones the
ambition but also you got a public
company you got to be able to represent
things to shareholders
for sure yeah and that's a great that's
a really great you know
i think that's a lot of people share
that perception of tesla
like okay they keep missing all these
targets they keep putting these things
out there to you know pump the stock and
they raise capital on those
you know goals that they're never going
to achieve you know that's a i wouldn't
say it's a fair criticism but it makes
sense why it exists
um but to your point you know stretch
goals exist for a reason this
you're trying to push your organization
you know 40 000 people 50 000 people at
tesla to try to accomplish something
that's never been done before
and to do that you need to set lofty
goals and you know swing for the fences
maybe you come up with a double but
um you know at least you you made
progress along the way
and i think from sort of tesla's
inception to maybe the last
probably about a year 18 months ago
that's really been how they've
managed things internally and also how
they have communicated with wall street
they've been very public about sort of
their internal targets
and inevitably they end up missing some
of those internal targets
i think we've seen a shift in the last
18 months and
this is reflected in the stock price now
where tesla has started to be
more conservative in the guidance that
they share with wall street
so that they can overachieve it and for
whatever reason
wall street really loves to have sort of
that okay you said you're going to do
this you've delivered on this stuff in
the past so i can count on at least
not getting my model wrong if you tell
me you're going to do this
so tesla i think has adopted that
strategy of okay we're just not even
going to give that much guidance and the
guidance that we do give is going to be
sort of
you know worst case type of scenario so
2020
annual delivery guidance is a perfect
example of that they said they should
comfortably exceed 500 000. that was
really their only guidance for the year
and even with the pandemic shutting down
their factories for you know a couple of
months
they're still likely to be able to
achieve that so if we
assume that that hadn't happened
obviously they would have been well
above
their targets so wall street really
likes to be able to
you know have confidence in what
management is saying and tesla hasn't
really given that to them
historically but i think they've sort of
shifted in how they've started operating
and i think that's a big part of what
we've seen
with the stock price this year one of
the things that
has always confounded me when people
talk about tesla is they focus on the
cars
and it's been pretty obvious for a long
time that this is very much a battery
company
and if they get the battery right the
car works but there's also potential for
other things around that battery
technology
uh you were just at battery day maybe
give us kind of an overview of just
how important is the battery technology
and kind of the ambitions there and then
what did you learn
at a battery day recently yeah so
battery day is i think an inflection
point i think the world changed this
week
for the better significantly and i don't
think a lot of people really fully
understand that or realize that yet the
reason that i say that is tesla
presented a path
to reducing the cost of batteries
per kilowatt hour so you know the cost
of energy
by 54 and tesla still has some work to
do to make sure all this happens and can
scale to volume production but they have
a clear
fundamental engineering scientific
approach to be able to do this that
they're highly confident
in being able to achieve so if you think
about you know the cost of a tesla
battery pack today
most estimates are that tesla's
producing each kilowatt
hour cost them about 120 110 something
like that
so if you have you know 100 kilowatt
hour pack you're at a 12 000
pack if tesla can achieve these things
that they set out to achieve
they're going to be able to deliver that
twelve thousand dollar pack for six
thousand dollars
and if we look at you know the pack in
the model three that goes from maybe
eight thousand dollars or nine thousand
dollars all the way down to about four
thousand dollars
so that's where you can start to see
this really clear path of okay if tesla
can cut out five thousand dollars
on the battery cost of the model three
and they you know if they take a 20
margin on that vehicle then really they
should be able to lower the price of
that by
six thousand dollars so then you're
looking at the vehicle with the
performance of the model three available
for
thirty thousand dollars and then you
factor in the cost of ownership savings
from
you know fueling up with electricity
versus filling up with gasoline
you're saving you know a thousand
dollars a year probably on that
depending on how many miles you're
driving and
what your gas prices are so it really
quickly starts to become competitive
with vehicles that cost
you know twenty thousand dollars and
these are the bare bones type of
vehicles
that are really just opening price point
of um you know a honda civic or
something like that
you know a lot of people are gonna opt
for a tesla model three versus a honda
civic and that's where you can start to
see a really clear path
to tesla basically just taking as much
market share as they can
happen to manufacture so
if if we start to go down that path um
then we can see
you know how tesla grows how the
internal combustion engine becomes
obsolete
and that's why i say this is an
inflection point because tesla's not
saying this is something that we
you know that we're targeting to achieve
this is tesla saying that
we have a plan in place that we have you
know already have
in pilot line type of operation uh that
we're gonna work towards and hopefully
achieve in two to three years
so the the other thing that they have
also said so that's sort of the cost
they're going to bring costs way down
the other thing that they've also done
is
increase the range that they can get out
of the vehicles so
there's a number of different changes
both within the battery cell and then
in terms of the actual design of the
vehicle so i'll give you an example
of just how how the design of the
vehicle has impacted
uh what tesla feels they can achieve
from a range perspective because
obviously historically electric vehicle
ranges have been sort of the prohibiting
factor
you know you need to be able to get far
enough you need to be able to charge it
that's
that's the big differentiator from a
gasoline engine perspective
so what tesla has done over time they've
tried to push those ranges higher and
higher for
more you know in a more affordable way
so
we talked about the cost in terms of the
range they've found ways to increase the
range
by 54 so then if we stack that on with
the cost savings
you're looking at you know the model 3
today if it gets 300 miles of range
that's going to be bumped up to you know
450 miles of range for about the same
same price or you can bring the cost
down et cetera
there's just a lot of flexibility there
and one example of the way that they
of a way that they've been able to do
that there's a multitude of different
things here
but they've really tesla really
approaches things from a first
principles design point of view so
they're trying to
you know build things from the ground up
every time and find the best way to do
it
rather than just sort of assembling
these different components together
so one example that they gave a battery
day of how they plan to do that is
they sort of took a lesson from the
airplane industry
historically airplanes had stored the
fuel inside
the wings but there was sort of a fuel
tank process
in that so there'd be like the wing of
the airplane that you know sort of has a
shape like that
and then they put a little smaller tank
in there that has the fuel in it
and with that sort of design you've got
the fuel tank you know that adds weight
that adds
space you're just not getting as much
fuel in the wing as you possibly could
so at a certain point in time that
design was re-thought
and nowadays modern airplanes have the
entire sort of
wing structure act as the fuel tank so
instead of having
this fuel tank inside this wing
structure it's just all this so you get
more gravimetric energy density
you get more volumetric energy density
so similar thing has been
taking place in the automotive electric
vehicle design space
where people are taking these battery
cells and just sort of
placing them inside the structure in the
floor of the vehicle
and um what tesla's planning to do in
sort of their next iteration of their
vehicle design
is say okay we're going to do the same
thing with airplanes said we're going to
take that and instead of
placing these these battery cells inside
the structure of the vehicle we're going
to actually make the battery cells
the structure of the vehicle so they're
going to turn the battery casing
into a structural component that
actually provides you know stiffness to
the vehicle
and rigidity and things like that so
they can get more of the actual active
materials
because they're eliminating those parts
that before we're providing structure
and instead just having the battery cell
perform that function
um so that's adding like a 15 increase
in range and there's just a whole lot of
list of
a whole long list of ways that tesla's
planning on doing this that they walk
through
in battery day that sort of add up to
that that 54
so i think a lot of that stuff is not
appreciated and again that's where
you know tesla continues to show that
they're sort of leaps and bounds ahead
of
competitors which really aren't thinking
about anything like that
because they have to figure out okay how
can we make this vehicle fit
you know a gas-powered engine and also
batteries and things like that it's just
not the design approach that they have
what's so interesting to me is uh what
you're talking about
here is a fairly technical um kind of
in the weeds type innovation for example
right
uh and that would be uninteresting to 99
of people
except tesla has made a really really
cool car
and it's become a status symbol and
uh almost been an aspirational type
product now
uh and it feels like if that wasn't the
way that the company was built in the
brand and things like that
this would have been over a long time
ago right like this was the only way to
do that do you get the same sense or do
you have a different view
yeah i think so i mean the tesla's
really the only automaker in sort of the
last hundred years that has been able to
sort of get to volume production and be
profitable and that was always a
critical argument for tesla as we talked
about before you know the moving goal
posts of
of the criticisms against tesla it's
always been okay tesla's not profitable
now the last four quarters they have
been profitable they have been
profitable in part due to
regulatory credit sales that they have
sold to other automakers
which are you know offset penalties that
those other automakers would have
because of emissions requirements that
they weren't able to meet so tesla's not
getting government money they're just
selling it to competitors that you know
failed to meet those requirements
uh but that has impeded their
profitability so now it's okay tesla's
not profitable without the regulatory
credits
but when we go to next year you know
that's not going to be a factor anymore
well
it'll still be a factor but it's not
going to be the driving source of
profitability
so there have been those criticisms
against tesla over time
um but back to the original point there
hasn't been an automaker that has been
able to be successful and i think tesla
sort of
threaded that needle in a very unique
way and
a lot of that has been due to you know
elon musk as sort of the original
financier of the company he was willing
to put sort of every last dollar that he
had
to make sure that tesla was able to
survive you know that really painful
period of
being a startup not having capital not
having investors believe in the
long-term mission
um not being able to you know have that
money available to make sure you can get
through to the next
to the next level and tesla has kind of
had to do that for the
you know the 17 years that they've
existed prior to sort of last year where
they finally started to become
profitable through just economies of
scale so you know that's a 15-year long
process
a lot of companies don't have the
ability to go that long without being
profitable
especially at sort of that scale where
you know you're manufacturing vehicles
that's
really expensive you don't have the
luxury of of having those software
margins that like an internet startup
might have
so it's really difficult and i think
tesla was
i don't want to say fortunate but sort
of uniquely positioned and that they
were creating that disruptive technology
if we think about you know other
electric vehicle startups
today they have to compete with tesla
tesla didn't have to compete with tesla
so it's just i think it's going to be
really tricky for any you know other
new electric vehicle mark makers to sort
of follow that same path because
tesla's already there and they have to
compete with the specs that tesla has
been able to achieve already with the
economies of scale so
yeah it's a really tricky path and i
think tesla was sort of all the stars
aligned to
be able to carry them through that path
where are we going right and what i mean
by that is if you would talk to
a kathy wood at arc invest or some of
these other folks who are
ultra ultra uh bullish on tesla and the
battery technology and elon
they'll tell you that this is you know
the next great
company and not even car company but
just the next great
company how do we get there and kind of
how big do you think this gets
just kind of walk me out you know 10 or
20 years from now like what does this
look like is you know what is the
company still around right you know or
do they not make it
um and kind of like what do you envision
um that this turns into uh fully
understanding that uh
you're commenting from the outside but
kind of how do you see it
yeah for sure i think the first part is
yeah i expect tesla will be around i
think they've
they've made it through sort of those
difficult time periods i think the model
3 was sort of that
you know sort of inflection point of
will tesla make it or will they not
the demand is proven now the
profitability is proven now
they obviously can access capital very
easily now with the market cap that they
have so
i think assess to her success to some
degree
is assured maybe that's not reflected in
necessarily the return in the market but
i think tesla will exist that's sort of
the base case
um as we look at you know why i'm
invested significantly in the company
it's really because i do believe that
tesla can continue to scale
and that the competition is going to
continue to struggle to deliver a
product that can be competitive
with tesla you know even today they're
not really delivering
electric vehicles that are competitive
and that's before considering that
they're probably not even profitable on
those vehicles and a lot of the
you know funding for those vehicles is
provided again because they need to
offset those
uh those regulatory credit requirements
across different countries so
um i think i think the gap between tesla
and competitors is continuing to grow
and i think that will
allow them to sort of as fast as they
can scale production
continue to grow deliveries continue to
grow revenue continue to grow profit
and reinvest that for future growth so
that's really what they walked through
at battery day they said that they
plan to scale battery production
internal tesla battery production to
three terawatt hours per year
by 2030. so i think a lot of people
don't really fully understand what that
means
a tesla battery pack and the model 3 of
the model y is 75 kilowatt hours
3 terawatt hours is 40 million of those
per year like that's that's a
that's absolutely insane the amount of
energy capacity that tesla is trying to
target
by 2030 so not all that is going to go
to producing 40 million vehicles
tesla has aspirations to you know they
sell energy storage products that
can be tied in with the grid to you know
help buffer
you know spikes and legs and energy
production capacity things like that
but even at your house you can you know
if you have solar production obviously
that's only producing energy
for you know 12 hours a day and then you
have to store that energy so you can use
it overnight
in an energy storage product so the grid
can act as that or you can have it on
site and sort of a tesla battery product
uh so tesla believes that that that
business is going to grow as well over
the next decade and maybe
uh 50 of their battery production you
know sort of end state
would go to sort of those energy storage
products 50 percent to
to vehicles so they're really targeting
more around long term
producing about 20 million vehicles per
year which as we talked about before
would be
sort of two times the scale of of toyota
so
because of tesla's advantages and how
they're positioned right now and
how there is this clear path to tesla
producing a 25
000 electric vehicle that's really not
all that different from the model 3
today
i think i'm pretty confident that tesla
can achieve that
and can take as much market share as
they can produce so
that's sort of my perspective i think
tesla will get to somewhere around that
10 million 20 million vehicle
mark uh within a decade maybe it's a
couple years longer like we talked about
before
but that as we talked about when you
start to add in the software margin
there's a very clear path to tesla being
a multi-trillion dollar
valuation company and on three terawatt
hours of battery production
that should pretty easily get them to
you know a trillion dollars in revenue
per year
when we mix automotive and energy
storage so right now the you know the
highest generating highest revenue
generating company in the world is
walmart
at about half a trillion you know 520
billion per year
uh so i believe tesla's got a really
really clear path that they walked
through at battery day
to sort of double the highest grossing
company right now
so that's sort of my perspective and
then the other the other bullish layer
which you know arc invest is very
excited about is the potential for
tesla to deliver you know an autonomous
robo taxi network type of situation
that would really just take the place of
what uber and lyft do today
but cut out all the labor and then cut
out all the costs of
the internal combustion engine you know
vehicle as we talked about before
electric fuel or electric you know
energy is about five times cheaper than
uh what it would cost for for gasoline
so tesla
if they can achieve sort of this
autonomous vehicle that they're working
really hard to achieve
um they should have a very clear you
know clear-cut grasp on that entire sort
of
transportation as a service type of
market uh which can be extremely
high margin for tesla which again sort
of just breaks the valuation and that's
why you see these
you know really bullish price targets
for for tesla um from companies like arc
invest
i think pre-split they had a their their
highest case price target on tesla was
like 24 000
a share uh which would be you know for 4
500
a share now something like that um post
split
so yeah i mean that's that's sort of
the bold case is tesla scales up to be
this massive player in the automotive
market they develop
autonomy uh which we can you know talk
talk for hours about that alone but
really though the whole bowl case on
tesla and autonomy is that tesla's got
these this fleet of you know a million
vehicles out there right now and that's
going to double every year or two
as tesla girls production with eight
cameras radars ultrasonics on them
uh that are just collecting all this
data from all these customers driving
around all the time
nobody else has that a company like
waymo maybe they've got you know
a couple thousand vehicles that they're
managing they have to
pay to produce them they have to pay
engineers to drive them around things
like that
tesla actually gets paid by their
customers to get these vehicles on the
road
and then their customers just drive them
around for them so
tesla has a very clear path to scaling
to acquire that data and it really is at
the end of the day
you know a data problem um that tesla is
you know positioned to
acquire the most data so i feel good i
don't know when tesla will get to an
autonomous vehicle type of situation
what matters to me is that tesla's
strategy appears to be the one that
would be the leading strategy
so whether it's 2025 2030 2035 it
doesn't really matter too much to me as
long as i see tesla
position in sort of that leadership
space
makes uh makes a lot of sense before we
move into the rapid fire questions that
i
ask everyone uh talk a little bit just
about tesla daily and kind of how you've
built what you've built and where people
can find you and the various platforms
you're on
yeah so like i said before apple podcast
is sort of the original um
tesla daily podcast i'm on youtube so
just search for tesla daily should come
up
and then i also write a column at the
street also under the sort of the tesla
daily brand
uh so i've been doing that for a few
months now and that just sort of every
day gives
really the most important thing that
happened in tesla
that day and sort of a 300 word article
or something so if you don't have time
to listen to
10-15 minute podcast each day which you
know that in and of itself is pretty
quick but
if you've only got a couple minutes
every morning to just read something
that's what i recommend
i try to just hit the highlight you know
every single day as best i can
got it that's the same two questions to
everybody and then you'll get to ask me
when to finish up the first is what is
the most important book that you've ever
read
honestly i don't read a ton of books
which i think is probably not an answer
you get a lot on this podcast
i definitely you know i do read books
but i read
constantly but i'm reading online
everything that i can online everything
i've learned from tesla has pretty much
been
online just from you know hearing
different owners talk about
what do you want so just everything
obviously everything so forums uh for
tesla's tesla motors club forum
reddit uh you know all the different
blogs like electric teslarati
so i'm constantly reading these things
and then just constantly
um trying to find new
informative people that i can follow and
understand and i think twitter's a great
a great place for that there's so many
people sharing so much valuable
information that
is extremely timely and that's where i
think you know i lose a little bit of
interest in sort of the
the book sort of infrastructure is it
takes
and like books are important too i don't
want to sell them short but
um you know my interests are more in
like what is happening
right now and things are changing so
fast that
the process of writing a book might take
a year or two and by the time you
publish it all that information might be
out of date
and there's so much good information
that people are sharing you know whether
it's on youtube whether it's on twitter
whether it's in
their blog whatever the case is people
are sharing awesome stuff
every single day and i feel like there's
by the time i catch up with all that
stuff there's no time left in the day
for me to sort of go through and sit
down and read a book
so i should probably change that and
it's something i think a lot about but
you know that's where my time gets
captured is just reading everything
online
um i'm actually very similar i read
books you know kind of
really important ones i want to sit and
like really really go through but for
the most part i consume
podcasts audio books and then uh
basically screw around on the internet
and look for
look for cool stuff right so exactly i
don't think that that is uh that
that uh uh abnormal if you will let's go
it makes me feel better since we are
speaking of elon this second question is
more fun but also uh
somewhat uh related which is aliens uh
believer or non-believer and uh and you
can also throw in any comments you have
about spacex and the other work he does
sure yeah so aliens uh it's tough you
know i think the
the likelihood that there's not some
sort of intelligent life form out there
in the galaxy is
or in the universe is extremely low but
then you run into the fermi paradox of
like okay if
if they exist why have they not
contacted us
um but i think you know probably the
solution to that is
okay somebody has to be first in sort of
exploring the universe so
why can't we be the one the first ones
to do that um
so yeah i don't know i kind of go back
and forth but i think it's i think it's
unlikely that we're sort of the only
ones
what are your thoughts on if i could ask
a question what are your thoughts on
that
uh absolutely i think uh from a
mathematical perspective just
very probable uh aliens exist the two
questions
are um are they uh
close enough or technology progress
gonna hit so like in our lifetimes will
we ever come in contact
right uh probably less likely um and
then also
are humans and aliens here in our
uh you know kind of on the same time
continuum if you will or time spectrum
so
uh yeah aliens maybe existed but they
were here a million years before humans
got here right humans are here for our
you know million years or whatever and
then there's
something else so it's uh it's
definitely kind of hard to uh
to to unpack uh but from a pure
existence forget time forget contact
uh i think that you gotta say look
there's gotta be life you know somewhere
else right
yeah it just seems extremely unlikely
that it wouldn't be the case
absolutely uh you can ask me one more
question usually everyone gets asked me
a question
so if you want if you got one more great
if not we can we can end it
yeah i think you know you're also a
content creator i would just
be curious to hear sort of your
perspective on you know what
what's what's the favorite part for you
of what you do
learning by far like not even close uh i
joke all the time when i tell people
i would do this if no one was watching
right because it's just
uh i get it i mean right i just got a
crash course on tesla from somebody who
spends
all day thinking about learning about
reading about tesla and
uh it's kind of a cheat code for life
right and learning
um now most people wouldn't come on the
podcast if i didn't have the audience
right so it's kind of the the uh you
know the value prop is hey you come
teach me everything and you also be
teaching a bunch of other people at the
same time
but i think that's definitely the thing
i get you know most enjoyment out of
it's just learning kind of on a daily
basis and i'm assuming that you're
you're pretty similar yourself yeah
absolutely and you know that goes back
to the start you know what you said
you'd be doing it if there wasn't an
audience you know we all start out that
way
you start doing it there's no audience
the audience builds over time because
i think we you know probably have this
passion for uh
for learning and then also helping
people sort of understand um
things and you know back to the point
about what we spend our time doing on
the internet like
we're we're so fortunate to live in a
time where all this information
is just so accessible to everybody that
really if you want to learn about
something
you can you just got to go out and do it
you got to do the work um
so i i'm i kill myself as being lucky to
help people start to
you know learn in whatever small little
segment of the internet that i'm on so
yeah that's definitely the best part i
love it all right rob listen thank you
so much for doing this uh i
heavily suggest everyone go check out
tesla daily podcast
youtube uh or the column at the street
you're doing an amazing job and i've
learned so much from you so
thanks so much for doing this yeah
thanks so much for having me great talk